you've heard of him you've seen his
crazy personality you felt his energy
Gary Vaynerchuk is one of the most
polarizing people out today he's an
entrepreneur who first got his start
trading baseball cards back in
elementary school from there he started
working for his family's wine company
and in no time he took that over and
proceeded to double their sales in
record time
now he runs his own media agency and
helps to motivate thousands of hustlers
and entrepreneurs to really go get it
and crush it in their business and in
life there is someone I look up to a lot
when it comes to confidence when he
talks you listen I've always been
fascinated by how he's able to gain
control of a room it's absolutely
amazing but before we get to that where
are my manners my name is Edwin Torres
and this is a potential new series here
on evans channel where we analyze and
breakdown the behaviors of some of the
most successful people in history in
this video I want to show you three
powerful ways to command a room just
like Gary Vaynerchuk
I've seen a lot of his videos and I've
picked up on the subtle things he does
below the surface that you can use to
command more respect and authority let's
get started the first thing Gary does
really well in conversation is he takes
charge and becomes the leader of it I
love getting punched in the mouth I love
it I love it I love it I love it I want
it it makes me want to stick it to
everybody who judged me when they judged
my fail well that's it I like it I know
no I actually love it you just kind of
like it I remember like at one point I
was maybe 19 or 20 and this is when I
was starting to get fat and I was fat oh
yeah like real that wasn't fat when you
guys met you were like there's a fat
dude but I like him I'm about 60 pounds
out of here you look great now thank you
appreciate I just got a personal trainer
two months ago or a month ago sorry and
how long have you been rocking five
o'clock shadow cuz yours is good what's
the size of guys do you think don't know
who you are
in that scenario and by the way why are
you dating in the real world what is
should I be dating in the internet world
like the way you do everything now I am
and that's that's very easy you just put
in your bio now know you'll have a
convert
nobody swiping right and then saying
well tell me about you like they know um
okay instead of going into a room and
taking a secondary or submissive role
Gary makes it a point to put his own
mark on the conversation some people can
argue that this makes you come across as
arrogant you can make others think that
you're just an intention seeker so it's
very very very important that you do
this in a covert and subtle way here's
how it's done I like to call it value
giving versus value taking you have to
become someone who always gives out
value and good energy instead of just
always expecting it back in return now
that we brought up this concept of value
it's important that we define what value
is value is the importance worth or
usefulness of something in the context
of a conversation value is what you tell
someone that ends up having a positive
effect on them or value can also be
giving through emotions if someone makes
you feel happy motivated energized or
any other range of feelings then they're
giving you value a good way to gauge if
someone is giving you value is to ask
yourself once you're done talking to
them how do I feel right now do I feel
energized and vibrant or do I feel
drained and bored that's a good way to
kind of check if they're giving you
value or they're just trying to take it
from you if you notice and interviews
Gary is always a value giver he's not
afraid to make you laugh he's not
hesitant to give you a piece of business
life or relationship advice I can really
put you on the right track in the
direction that you want to go in Gary's
just always tried to help people out
he is always giving out value I give and
have zero expectations the chips will
fall where they are if it goes great
Mazel Tov if not I wasn't providing
enough value that's on me
give I'm not doing this interview for
any other reason then I know that it's
leverage for you and it's gonna put you
on and you couldn't use it for others
that you want to do and no good that
makes me feel that's real life if you've
got the right DNA and you're a 72 year
old female you have just as good of a
bad as a 27 year old dude but you've
been trained and story told to and
positioned and lived in a 50-year matter
that doesn't feel like this thing in
here is a practical way to build that
but it is since she's always giving our
value you love being around them and you
just want to listen to whatever he has
to say let's talk about the next point
another thing about Gary Vaynerchuk and
what allows them to command a room is
his body language fun fact 92% of
communication is nonverbal that means
that the words you use or the part that
everybody else thinks is the most
important really only makes up about 7%
of the entire conversation the part that
truly matters is your body language and
your voice you can tell me the most
life-changing piece of information in
the world but if your body languages are
off it's not going to have the same
effect or impact that you wanted it to
have I want you to take a close look at
Gary Vee and really check out his body
language in this next clip I think what
I'm good at is building a pillar up top
that creates content below dailyvee
askgaryvee show right and then all flows
from there where did this quote come
from I don't know
you know like somewhere along the way
that that's what's powerful and I think
you need to create I think one thing
that people struggle with is they need
they think they need to it needs to come
from them and it needs to come from the
structure down instead of got it and
that's why you wake up you're like damn
I'm not feel like you know how hard it
is to manifest that kind of original
creative thing from the bottom but if
you if you may if you literally lived
your life under show think of yourself
as like CNN or MSNBC Monday is odd
corner sit like if you're white boarded
now on like many shows that you could do
Mondays odd corner Tuesday
like subway shots Wednesday's like
suburbs just literally going out all
right what does he do well he comes
across present and engaged he looks at
ease his body language is nice and open
it's not closed off and in word he's
also giving out strong eye contact and
can really feel that coming off from him
he also is projecting his voice you can
hear every single thing that he's saying
and all of these things put together
makes him come across as a confident and
strong communicator but don't worry
these are all things that you can
practice right now here's what I want
you to do the next person you speak to I
want you to do this be vulnerable with
your body language make sure your arms
and legs are nice and open
don't put your hands inside your pocket
make sure when you're walking don't look
down look up and directly ahead of you
the next thing speaks 15% louder make
sure you project your voice and whatever
you do do not be shy okay make sure you
speak nice and loud because you you
right there you watching this video
right now you deserve to be heard so act
like it
in the final tip if people saw that I
contact you know when you're talking to
someone and you feel the awkwardness and
the tension rising and you just want to
look away don't do it okay hold that I
contact one or two seconds longer and
trust me it's gonna have a amazing
effect on how you come across to them
you're gonna come across more confident
and trustworthy and you're going to feel
super good as well and now let's talk
about the last tip if you want to
command the room and you have to be at
the cause and not the effect what does
this mean when you're at the cause
you're the influencing factor you're the
captain of your ship you're taking
charge you're not letting things happen
by chance you're making things happen
when you're at the effect you're letting
things happen to you you're taking a
secondary role you're letting things
happen by chance you're not really being
in control and dominate and really going
for what it is that you want you're just
like a leaf in the wind and wherever the
wind blows that's the direct
now you're going to go in listen instead
of being worried about what other people
might say or what they might not say or
what they potentially could or maybe
might not maybe one day could
potentially maybe not maybe yes maybe no
say I want you to mentally decide that
from this moment on you're going to be
at the cause and not the effect I am
tired of people not starting and living
their life on one very simple thing
which is they're worried about what
other people think whether that's their
mom their friends and worst of all
comments in social media I mean this is
some sixth grade lunchroom Shh are you
really really really not gonna live your
life based on somebody's anonymous icon
feedback that you suck they suck
there's three crash that's what found a
dumpster what Gary does reading one of
these clips as you can see his passion
for life he doesn't let his excuses hold
him back he's not afraid to call other
people out for their own BS he's not
hesitant or afraid to do whatever he
wants to do Gary doesn't care he's at
the cause and not the effect seriously
from now on ask yourself what do I feel
like doing or saying right now and then
go do it but the whole point of this tip
is for you to start living a more
authentic life don't do something just
because someone else tells you to do it
do it because you want to do it that's
the easiest way to live a happier and
more fulfilled life this will not only
help you skyrocket your self-esteem but
I'll help other people become
magnetically drawn to you and there you
have it those are my three biggest tips
if you want to command the room just
like Gary Vaynerchuk let's recap them
really fast
number one become the leader of the
conversation make sure you put your mark
on it so people know exactly where you
stand
number two practice strong and effective
body language that means looking people
in the eye projecting your voice and
being nice and open everywhere you go
number three be at the cause and not the
effect do or say what you want to do or
say without overthinking it
you're in control of your own life if
you liked this video make sure you leave
a comment below I'm always open to
improved so whatever feedback you have
I'm all ears
and also let me know which one of these
tips was your favorite I love to know
that too I had fun until next time this
is Edwin Torres from next-level
confidence peace
terrific world domination honey Empire
right I'm grateful I understand why I'm
here I think because I am so open I
wanted to think I see it's a bloody
brief life all of you have the potential
for enormous success if you want to know
what Gary Vee DJ Khalid Oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video